[Música]
y hoy les voy a invitar a un viaje así
que por favor pónganse cómodos estén
atentos y tomen mucha atención durante
los cultores de los siguientes años
durante los pasados años peruanos
tendrán todos pasados años he tenido la
oportunidad de vivir y de viajar a
muchos países
en diferentes continentes ahí van a ir
apareciendo un poco unas cuantas de mis
fotos
y bueno todo el mundo habla de lo que
aprende
mientras vive o viaja al exterior hoy yo
les voy a hablar de lo que he tenido que
desaprender solo un poco raro no toda la
vida nos han enseñado
tenemos que aprender cosas pero yo me
dado cuenta que a veces tenemos que peso
aprender cosas para aprender otras
nuevas
escucha este término desaprender una vez
en la universidad haciendo la maestría
profesor hablaba como tenemos que
desaprender cosas para poder tratar con
personas efectivamente él decía que para
trabajar tenemos que olvidarnos de las
creencias que tenemos de que las
personas de cierto país son de una forma
o de cierta ciudad son de una forma o un
género es de una forma o de la edad es
de una forma y cuando lo decía yo lo
veía tan interesante pero solamente lo
veía en ese momento como para
relacionarme con personas no pero luego
me di cuenta de que se realmente
relaciona con todo muchas veces
aprendemos cosas mientras crecemos cosas
útiles claro que sí como por ejemplo
cuando somos niños y nos enseñan a no
meter los dedos en el interruptor no
útil nos salva la vida nos enseñan a
mirar a los dos lados antes de cruzar la
calle útil también pero hay muchas
muchas otras cosas que aprendemos que no
son tan útiles y que en vez de ser
útiles nos limitan por ejemplo nos dicen
que las mujeres deben comportarse de una
forma porque los hombres deben ser de
una forma aunque cierta edad te permite
hacer unas cosas
te permite hacer otras y esas ideas
queramos o no se quedan
inconscientemente nuestros cabezas
me di cuenta de esto así como como tal
cómo terminó de desaprender un día que
estaba yendo a la estaba alistando cosas
para viajar estaba metiendo mis cosas
como logré en la maleta en la mochila
además en la mochila estaba esperando
porque además como la mayoría de mis
viajes es en el medio de la noche estaba
había llamado al taxi estaba esperando
bajo me subo y me llama mi mamá y me
pregunta está subiendo al aeropuerto
y yo estas veces vivía en washington
aquí en la foto en el aeropuerto en el
avión ven alguna subida
no entonces dije un momento no estoy
subiendo al aeropuerto verdad estoy
camino al aeropuerto sí pero tiene
sentido porque esto es el alto y la paz
y para subir de la paz al aeropuerto del
alto
si hay una subida evidentemente y claro
mi mamá ha crecido he vivido en la
ciudad de la paz con su vida entonces
para ella la idea de llegar al
aeropuerto implicaba subir
y ahí me di cuenta y pensé qué fácil que
es creer que todas las cosas son como
queríamos que son como hemos aprendido
que son así
y entonces voy a hablarles hoy de eso de
las cosas que he tenido que desaprender
aprender cosas nuevas y la primera de
las que quiero hablarles es de esta
el dinero no limita tus experiencias y
ahora vamos a aprender a pretender que
estamos en un viaje sí entonces
imagínense que quieren viajar que tienen
estas ganas locas de viajar que es lo
primero que piensan
de hecho muy bien no tengo plata o
cuando tenga plata cuando ahora cuando
la herencia cuando me paguen cuando
trabaje si verdad siempre pensamos eso
porque es lo primero que nos han
enseñado que viajar es caro además que
especialmente aquí en la paz
viajar es a veces esto no queremos irnos
a un hotel un resort o -inclusive todo
incluido queremos ahí que nos a banic en
con hojas y que comer y beber todo lo
que queramos porque claro ya sufrió la
mayor parte del año tiene sentido que
queremos irnos a la playa pero la verdad
es hemos aprendido además eso es viajar
no eso es vacación pero a veces esa idea
nos limita de lugares fascinantes
que también son viajes que también son
vacaciones a veces en nuestro propio
país en nuestra propia ciudad porque
creemos que tenemos que irnos puesto al
caribe que tenemos que irnos a miami y
nos olvidamos de las cosas que tenemos
aquí esto es huayna potosí cerca viaje
de un día dos se quieren quedarse
pero tenemos que quitarnos la idea de
que el otro
este es el viaje ideal y entender que
hay otras formas de hacerlo y que además
ahora bueno ahora en estas épocas hay un
millón de oportunidades hay vuelos
baratos a escalas muchas veces que yo he
viajado hecho escalas de un día de dos
días de tres porque lo más barato pero
que me permitía eso conocer otra ciudad
conocer otro país exactamente a veces se
encuentran para vuelos más baratos que
buses a veces buses de un dólar
encontrado pero hay hay que buscar pero
empiezas a buscar que no te quitas la
idea de que es imposible
y además a otra parte de los esperan
tenemos que tenemos que ir esto tel
súper caro con todo incluido y de
repente descubres que hay esas opciones
muchos de mis viajes han sido australes
no comparte su habitación sí pero
conoces mucha gente de todo el país de
todo el mundo perdona o también de
repente conozco y conocido a alguien que
me dice que mi prima está en parís
entonces de repente yo también puedo ir
y así vas conociendo y vas encontrando
personas que te pueden hospedar y esas
son formas en las que puede viajar
formas en las que hay que quitarse de la
cabeza de que es imposible y hacer y
otro de los ejemplos que tengo por
ejemplo es bueno que esto es los viajes
algunos de ellos otro hábito no es
estudiar en el extranjero la misma idea
pensar que es imposible pensar que es
para gente millonario hablar genios
quítense desidia de la cabeza porque si
yo he podido cualquiera de ustedes
podría hacerlo hay un millón de
oportunidades y cada vez hay más y el
mundo quiere además gente como nosotros
gente con ganas gente boliviana gente
bueno digamos que en el viaje ya han
superado esta etapa del miedo que no
tenían dinero bueno tengo un poco de
ahorros y después de conseguir al primo
que me va a esperar y ya tengo todo
entonces que viene después
en el comprar el hacerlo hacerlo y ahí a
veces tenemos otras limitaciones
que no hay mis amigos no quieren ir que
no puede sacar vacaciones al igual que
todos que quien me va a acompañar como
voy a ir
suele pasar cuantos han pensado en eso
es verdad muchas veces cuando yo quería
viajar me decían pero con quién vas a ir
y las primeras perdido varias
oportunidades porque no había con quién
ir hasta que un día dije
voy sola imagínense el grito de mi madre
cuando se enteró eso porque claro hemos
aprendido que las mujeres no viajan
solas no que es peligroso que todo se
puede pasar y encerrar a un montón de
veces en mis viajes me ha pasado un
montón de cosas que yo así pensé que
ella es el final pero todo el tiempo a
la roben el pasaporte decía necesito
esto para volver y nada más
y a veces y enfrentes cosas útiles y una
de las cosas que útiles que aprendido es
por ejemplo que te dicen cuando eres
niño y te asusta aquí en la paz
sí pero se te sale algo
eso se te sale todo años no te asustas
de salida y luego queremos volver a
llamarlo y todo vuelve a estar bien
literal lo voy a aplicar está levantada
he dicho que puede pasar
te vuelves a llamar vuelves en sí y
sigues adelante
porque eso es si nos quedamos esperando
a que las condiciones se den a que tenga
el dinero a que alguien venga conmigo a
que se me pase la enfermedad que esto
pase seguimos esperando y esperando y
esperando porque hemos aprendido que
tenemos que hacer eso dejamos pasar
oportunidades
luego otra cosa que aprendido es que no
hay una forma correcta de hacer las
cosas no hay una sola definitivamente no
estaba viviendo en el exterior y un
amigo de mi mamá me estaba ayudando y él
me dice tienes que conseguir que una
compañera de casa no está buscando dónde
vivir me dice una latina porque
necesitan extrañar a nuestros latinos
somos nosotros así somos trata necesitas
una compañera latina
yo he creído también he aprendido no
somos lo más conocido que tenemos
primera vez que estaba afuera pero no
podía darme el lujo ya no tenía el
tiempo para buscar así que agarrado y
otros lugares y mis dos compañeras en
diferentes años por las dos una demanda
de es la otra de indonesia si hubiera
escuchado eso me hubiera empecinado en
buscar una chica latina tal vez iba a
conocer una gran persona así pero me
hubiera perdido las grandes cosas que
aprendido sobre asia viviendo con dos
personas asiáticas
grandes cosas y se han convertido en
grandes grandes grandes amigas
por ejemplo esto es una cosa que una de
ellas comía la fruta
con sal y complicado luego ido méxico y
claramente con poco más conocido me
moría de sed y me ofrecen sandía yo así
que rica sandía fresca listo le ponen
picante encima carne porque además de un
comunicante pero ya vemos acercarlo gol
entonces he dicho no el fondo se puede
he probado igual he probado ha sido de
las únicas cosas que no he podido
terminar este vídeo que decir ya no
puedo más pero aprende claro en nuestra
cabeza que hemos aprendido la fruta es
postre o es dulce y
bueno me escuchan bueno me escuchan muy
bien bueno entonces que hemos aprendido
que la fruta es dulce que la fruta es
postre y que eso es lo que tenemos que
así nomás es de repente te dan un día
con picante y tu esquema se mueve pero
tienes que aprender que en otros lugares
la gente los ha diferente y otra cosa
que he aprendido de mis compañeros de
dacia por ejemplo que la palta es un
postre
un día me han visto preparando para
tomar mi cafecito con mi falta y me han
dicho que estás haciendo porque le pone
sal y yo como he porque el fondo sal y
me han dicho eso es un postre ha sido
una de las grandes discusiones que hemos
tenido pero pero eso me ha permitido
aprender a hacer un pudín de chocolate y
konko con palta aguacate que es una de
las mejores cosas que prepara porque
pero para eso tengo que quitarme de la
cabeza de eso aprender que la palta
heras álava que la palta era para el té
no que era para una ensalada
esas son ideas pequeñas pero es para
todo es lo mismo con la gente creemos
que al otro lado por ejemplo había gente
que me decía pero no te juntes con
muchos latinos busca gente europea busca
entre otro lado te dicen las dos causas
y es verdad y si hubiera dejado que
cualquiera de las dos se meta o bien no
hubiera podido conocer a la gran
cantidad de personas maravillosas de
todo el mundo desde madagascar hasta
perú no de todo el mundo que he conocido
porque haya desaprendido me he quitado
los prejuicios me ha quitado las ideas
alguien es mejor que alguien porque me
ha dado cuenta de que no hay una forma
de hacer las cosas y que simplemente
todos lo hacemos diferente
y bueno no quiero que esta idea se quede
en que tienen que viajar y que tienen
que irse hacia madagascar mañana no
porque el aeropuerto y el avión del que
les estoy hablando ahora
es metafórico no se refiere a todo en
realidad porque a veces nos pasa vivimos
en nuestra burbuja no en nuestro barrio
en nuestro colegio a la universidad
nuestro trabajo y nos evitamos de
conocer personas de otras partes de la
ciudad de otras partes de nuestro mismo
país que hacen las cosas diferentes sí
cuántos de ustedes aquí son de otro
departamento den hacia la paz
bien ustedes no comen marqueta
se comen también muy bien pero con queso
todos los días esa alergia ha pasado
también de una vez que llegamos a
destino hemos logrado viajar llegamos al
lugar donde tenemos que ir estamos no sé
costa rica donde se come frijoles
almuerzo desayuno y cena además me ha
tocado comer los tres que nunca hablar
más que tienes de frijoles y de repente
te toca almuerzos hay una escena y yo
era como donde estaba y marraqueta no te
lo tienes que quitarte no va a haber no
vas a encontrar ahí estás en otro país
es otra cosa tienes que aprender a
apreciar ya a ver de qué sirve de dónde
viene esto porque lo hacen que puedo
sacar de bueno de esto y aprender a
hacerlo de esa forma y como les digo es
una metáfora son cosas que pueden hacer
todos los días desde la música que
escuchas desde aprender un idioma comer
comida de otros lugares ahora ahí estoy
de vuelta ahora cada vez está más a la
disposición cocina de otros lugares
comida vegetariana prueben intente vayan
a comer comida mexicana comida bueno que
haya más comida china cómo tratarnos
intentemos porque no siempre podemos
agarrar un avión e irnos
pero siempre podemos intentar ver una
película en otro idioma saquemos ya lo
que siempre hemos aprendido el mismo
tipo de películas intentemos otras sin
subtítulos a ver si se puede saber si
entienden algo o intentaremos arriesgué
monos porque nos han enseñado muchas
veces que tenemos que tener cierta
condición para lograr cosas que tenemos
que ser de ciertos de cierta forma que
tenemos que comportarnos de cierta forma
y todas esas creencias todo eso que
hemos aprendido y si todo eso te limita
tenemos que desechar porque así hacemos
más espacio para crear ideas que nos
ayuden a crecer y como dice el tema de
esta charla de este evento para crear
oportunidades y de repente tal vez
podemos aprender
que hay más de una forma de llegar al
aeropuerto gracias